kevin comió 5 rebanadas de pastel es
christopher comió cuatro rebanadas si
quedaba una rebanada que fracción de
pasteles se comió vamos a hacer esto de
una manera gráfica y entonces tenemos
nuestro espacio para dibujar tenemos
entonces un pastel vamos a dibujar
nuestro pastel y lo pintaré de color
magenta
este pastel vamos a asumir que es
redondo
redondo redondo redondo redondo hoy es
lo más redondo que
ok tenemos un pastel redondo asumamos
que está perfectamente redondo y tenemos
5 rebanadas de kevin que bean
5 rebanadas
christopher comió cuatro rebanadas
y aún quedan vamos a poner
queda
una rebanada
esto indica que teníamos 5 rebanadas más
4 son 9 más una que queda son 10
este pastel estaba dividido en 10
rebanadas iguales vamos vamos a poner
aquí que son rebanadas iguales todas
no lo indica pero vamos a asumirlo para
que pueda hacer una fracción real
entonces tenemos vamos a dividir este
pastel en
5 en 10 rebanadas quedamos 549 unas son
es rebanadas
he vivido esto a la mitad
ahora dividiré en 35 cada mitad
más o menos así está dividido en cinco
cada parte
veamos entonces este va por la mitad y
tengo
porque tendría así 10 piezas del pastel
tenemos 10 rebanadas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
por favor pensemos que todas están
divididas de una manera igual ok vamos a
ver si kevin que lo tenemos en magenta
se comió 5 rebanadas que vi se comió 1
5 rebanadas
kevin comió cinco rebanadas de este
pastel
christopher
comió cuatro rebanadas una
parece que estuvo tenían hambre estos
señores porque comieron mucho
y 4
cuatro rebanadas de christopher y nos
indica que quedó una rebanada es
correcto nos quedó una rebanada
qué fracción de pasteles se comió
podemos saber que tenemos un total un
gran total de
10 rebanadas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
tenemos un gran total de 10 rebanadas
totales
cuántas de ellas se comieron 123456789
nueve rebanadas comidas
con esto sabemos entonces que como
fracción tenemos nueve de diez rebanadas
comidas o nueve décimos vamos entonces a
nuestro ejercicio y pongamos la
respuesta si queda una rebanada que
fracción de pasteles se comió nueve y
aquí pondremos una diagonal en la
computadora para poder indicar la línea
de la fracción la división entonces
tendremos nueve décimos comprobamos la
respuesta
y es correcta vamos a hacer uno más
louis comió cuatro rebanadas de pizza
christopher comió tres si inicialmente
había once rebanadas que fracción de
pizza se comió vamos a copiar este
problema escrito y lo copiaremos en un
espacio para que dibujemos
vamos a hacer una pizza un poco más
bonita
ok esta es la pizza que tenemos vamos a
dividirla en 11 rebanadas
10 y 11 ok pensemos que son 11 rebanadas
que son iguales
iguales
si luis vamos a poner a luis en másters
y luis se comió 4
esta es una
4 estas fueron las cuatro rebanadas de
louis
christopher
comió tres rebanadas
tres rebanadas si inicialmente había
once rebanadas ya las tenemos todas que
fracción de pizza se comió nos quedaron
libres una dos tres cuatro
así es que podemos decir que cuatro de
las once rebanadas totales
4 11 a voz de pizza quedo
sin comer
ahora vamos con los que sí se comieron
tenemos 1 2 3
siete rebanadas de pizza de un total de
once
se comieron
así es que podemos poner en nuestro
resultado que 711 a voz de la pizza se
comió vámonos a nuestro ejercicio
pondremos entonces 7
11 a voz de la pizza se comieron
comprobemos la respuesta
y es correcto